- My kids, my kids loved you as Aquaman.
Is it cool if I bring them out,
and maybe they ask you a couple questions?
- I would love to meet your children.
- Come on out Remy, come on out River.
Do you wanna give Aquaman a hug?
Do you wanna give him a hug?
You nervous?
Are you nervous?
Come here, are you nervous?
- Do you have kids?
- I do, I do have kids.
- You wanna sit, here,
I'll sit her by him,
and then you can sit, okay.
Here I'll sit you right
here, you good, you good?
- Oh my goodness, hi.
(laughs)
- I told, I was like, I
dunno if they're gonna,
usually my son, this is so funny,
cause usually Remy's on the
bed when we're watching,
and he's like I'm Aquaman.
- You got Aquaman shoes on right now.
- Oh my god, he's gonna cry.
Okay, Riv, why don't you take over?
You have a question for him?
- Yeah, I forgot.
- Okay, go ahead, oh you forgot?
Here I'll tell you, you
told me in the thing.
(whispers)
- Do you know little mermaid?
- Aw.
- That was her question in my office,
and I was like, ask him.
- Ariel, yeah, she's, Ariel's
very sweet, she's very nice.
She's also a redhead,
so I'm gonna teach you
about redheads some day.
(laughs)
They're very passionate,
very passionate people.
- That is true.
Ver, you had another
question in the office,
you want me to, okay here I'll help you.
Okay, cause they were like,
this is the best part, they
wrote out cards for her,
and I'm like she's in kindergarten.
She's learning how to read.
- Aw, thank you baby.
- Did you make the Ver, oh for our friend?
Oh my god that's so nice.
That's very sweet.
(whispers)
- Aquaman.
- Where does Aquaman go to the bathroom?
- That was what she asked in the office,
where does Aquaman go to the bathroom?
- Everywhere!
- That's cause you're in the
water all the time, oh my god.
Do you wanna ask him anything,
you wanna say anything Remy?
- Hey, you like Aquaman,
you watch it, come on.
- She's the talker and
he's the sensitive one.
- Hey, it's chill with Aquaman.
- He is so excited.
All right, well you guys did awesome.
Good job, good job Riv, you're so sweet.
Okay, I wanna say thank
you so much to Aquaman,
y'all wanna say thank you?
- Thank you.
(laughs)
- Remy is so nervous.